today I'm going to talk about quarks
you've probably heard about quarks as
elementary particles but I'd like to
introduce you to a simpler clock here it
is it is a Central European cheese
it's a curd cheese very popular in
Germany so this is my version of quarks
I'm going to talk about what the
evidence is for quarks because you've
never seen one apart from this that's
the first time you've seen it in fact a
theory of quarks was invented by two
different people at the same time one of
the big things that we try and do in
physics is to work out the building
blocks of nature what are the the Lego
bricks from which everything else
emerges you know whether it be the
chairs in the room the the doors you and
I before the 60s we just thought about
elementary particles as being protons
and neutrons with electrons whizzing
around them and the protons and the
neutrons were the smallest known
particles and they seem to be elementary
but gradually as more and more
experiments were being done in the turn
of the century and into the 1920s
we began to realize there were other
phenomena occurring which you wouldn't
have expected if the neutrons and the
protons were the basic building blocks
now in 1964 independently two guys came
up with the idea that the protons the
neutrons weren't elementary they were
made up of three other little particles
whizzing around each other these
particles were called aces by George
Zweig but history has forgotten him more
or less the other person murray
gell-mann called them quarks apparently
it's to do it came from heat from the
quark came from the quack of a duck okay
so that's where he knew he wanted
something like that and originally he
thought about the sound of a quacking
duck and he wanted it be cool oh oh I
know that the net that so the name
quarks was came from Murray gell-mann I
mean he's a very special man
it got Murray gell-mann one of the
brightest people I've ever come across
and
he invented the name and he had read
work by James Joyce an Irishman a poet
somebody who was a really wonderful
writer and there was this quotation in
his work Finnegan's Wake which is almost
unreadable three quarks or mr. mark
three quarks four and he used this idea
of quark as the basis of a very erudite
particle not mr. mark three quarks for
muster mark and I think it was simply
that the three was there and the quarks
were there and that sounded like quack
and he wanted the three because if you
remember he thought there was the up the
down and the strange and it all fitted
beautifully so you had these two
different things and aces is much
simpler but quarks well that's what
we've ended up with now the trouble with
this picture of quarks is that normally
when you want to find out what something
is made of you build a bit of Lego and
you want to find how it's done you smash
it to pieces and put it together again
well you try to do the same things with
protons and neutrons to see if it's made
of three particles and they stick
together with such strong forces the
more you pull away the more they want to
stick together so seemed impossible to
get any experimental evidence for the
existence of these parts at all and they
fell into disrepute the third stage of
the story is as a famous scientist
called Richard Freiman a theoretician
goes and sees the people doing
experiments in which electrons are
bashing into protons and he looks at the
results and realizes that he's got a way
of thinking about it that will give
evidence for the existence of these
particles within the proton and the way
he imagines it involves relativity which
is a weird subject but if you could
imagine sitting on the electron and
travelling at near the speed of light
any object you see instead of being
round becomes squashed like a pancake
and as such it becomes a two-dimensional
object and they call it pancakes inside
this two-dimensional object there are
three different blobs that are visible
to the electrons and they smash into one
blob another blob or another blob and
you can analyze the results of the
electron scattering and how it bashes
into this and scatters off just by
imagining there are three parts to this
which will scatter that was the smoking
gun with that they had actually seen
quarks separate entities but he didn't
want to call it quark straight away
because he was a bit more devilish than
than most people highly intelligent but
he had a wicked sense of humor and
didn't like to be bested so he imagined
there were three parts in this and
instead of calling them quarks he called
them part ons and probably did that to
wind his colleague Murray gell-mann up
because they were polar opposites in
character whereas dick firemen will wear
shirt sleeves addressed like this Murray
gell-mann will wear tweed and really be
responded whereas Murray gell-mann would
go to the Faculty Club and have nice
lunches on perfect plates he would go
down to the greasy spoon and have a
hamburger they were complete opposite
characters and didn't get along at all
and both there are absolute geniuses and
they shared the same secretary they
lived they had their two offices and
then in between them with they had the
secretary and both had a door into her
office and the people didn't know how to
talk to these two guys in the same
department because they were using
different names and it might get
confusing but eventually Murray
gell-mann won out and everybody has
called them quarks the proton is made
it's not as simple as the original
picture was because in the original
picture excuse me I'm going to take this
bit slice of apricot off and divide this
up into three so let's have three quarks
is one bit of quark over there look how
easy they are to separate in this model
and there's another one and there's a
third so in the original model put
forward by Murray gell-mann they were
just these three which have different
flavors so this flavor is just a word
and that this one is called up the next
one is called down and the next one is
called strange because it was totally
unexpected when it turned up and
originally gell-mann thought they were
just these three late
Terron people found that a more
consistent picture would come if we
divided these into two and imagine that
were six of them so now we get to the
stage where there are six quarks there's
an up and a down and this is called the
first generation because there are low
energy ones this is the second
generation they're higher energy and
that they took longer to appear this is
a strange and a charm quark and then
later on there was a bottom and a top
quark and this was found in 1995 quite
recently in my lifetime it seems just
the other day and that is the current
standing on the quarks that there are
these six quarks
they're coming three families or
generations you have the up and the down
form one you have the charm and the
strange from the second one and you have
the top and the bottom form the third
and they have very similar properties
except basically as you go from right to
left from the up and then to the charm
and then to the top the masses of these
particles increase and in fact the top
quark is something like let's see it's a
hundred and seventy or what a stupid
thing I'm about to try and do the up
quark is about two million electron
volts and the top quark is about a
hundred and seventy billion electron
volts so it's roughly ten to the five
ten hundred thousand times more massive
than the up so now we believe there are
just these six quarks but who knows if
they go to higher energy don't that
taste good there could be others
that's not us